according to the national committee on
pay equity this date symbolizes how far
into the year
women must work to earn what men earned
in the previous year okay
so what's often brought up the talking
point that you hear from a lot of people
on the left yes but also from a lot of
women across the spectrum is that women
make less money than men
and the implication there is that
they're doing the same job and putting
in the same amount of hours and somehow
making less money when in reality that
is not what's happening
so i want to go to national review has
an article by the great thomas soule i
don't know if you know him if you don't
know him you should he's brilliant he's
opined on pretty much everything in the
political space but he talks a lot about
the myth that is the pay gap let's read
a little bit from there
because he talks about the importance
that career decisions
come into play the amount of hours you
actually work come into play
let's take a look
women as a group do get paid less than
men as a group so he says that's true
but not for doing the same work women
average fewer annual hours of work than
men they work continuously for fewer
years than men since only women get
pregnant there's another controversial
statement he made only women get preg
thomas can't say that in 2022.
crazy world we live in and most women
are not prepared to instantly dump the
baby on somebody else to raise being a
mother is not an incidental sideline and
being a single mother can be a major
restriction on how much time can be put
into a job either in a year or over the
years so what he's saying is for one
reason or another
sometimes it's choice
sometimes it's you have a child you're
pregnant it's
not always easy to work through a
pregnancy you take a maternity leave
whatever it may be he's saying that men
put in more hours at a job they tend to
work more hours and as a result they
make more money because they're putting
in more hours okay
interesting though that he points out
which i thought
was really the crux of the whole
argument he says as far back as 1971
single women
in their 30s who had worked continuously
since high school earned slightly more
than men of the same description as far
back as 1969 academic women who had
never married earned more than academic
men who had never married so do you
understand why he's pointing that out
it's not about sex it's not about gender
it's about time
it's about time
it's about hours it's not like somebody
walks into a room
and they say oh well you're a man you're
a woman you're doing the same amount of
work we're gonna pay you differently
because men should get paid more no it's
about hours it's about decisions it's
about choice some women may decide they
don't want to work that many hours that
they want to prioritize work-life
balance that they want to stay home when
their kids really young they may make
those decisions some women may find
themselves in a circumstance where they
feel pressured to make that decision
that absolutely does happen or they may
feel that they
do a bulk of what's going on in the
house in terms of chores and whatnot and
then can't give all of their energy as
well to an outside job so maybe they
feel a little pressured in that area i'm
not saying that it's always because
women just say oh i have all the options
in the world and it's not sometimes you
feel a little pressure sometimes you
feel like you can't be everything all at
once to everybody but there are
decisions that are made and sometimes
it's elective
right so again this isn't just outright
gender discrimination
that's not what's happening here a lot
of this has to do with decisions being
made within a family
by a family so you have to also in
addition factor in what careers they
choose right
what careers do women choose i remember
that when i was in college and we were
talking to the education department
about something i had a major in spanish
literature but oftentimes a lot of
education majors would have a
concentration in spanish
most of the education majors were female
teachers don't make as much money a lot
when you look at finance and the arenas
of finance oftentimes you'll look in a
room and see a bunch of guys in new york
city that's how it looks sorry not all
guys but that is the reality of where do
women and where do men gravitate not all
but a lot
that is part of what goes into how much
money you make you decide to be a
teacher you know you're not going to be
making you know
800 grand a year
that's a decision that's a decision
okay
and again how much time you wanna take
you wanna a lot of women say i wanna
when i have my baby i wanna stay home my
mom stayed home with me i talked about
this my husband yesterday my mom stayed
home with me the first few years
she went back to work i think i was like
seven
she wanted that she wanted more than
anything her whole life to have a child
that was really important to her so they
made that decision together so did my
dad make more money yes
would it have been the case if they
decided not to have a child i don't know
my mom had a pretty great job i remember
when she was younger they always talk
about how she had this great job and she
left it she didn't want to do it she
wanted to have a daughter she wanted to
have a child she did want to have a
daughter but she wanted to have a baby
above all else so funny she always says
i wanted to have a daughter i want to
have daughter now she has a grandson and
she's obsessed with him so you never
know now it's like my boy my boy so you
never know
so why did i do the pay gap i did that
as a starter
because i think it's important people
throw talking points out a lot
you know about equality people throw
talking points out we were talking with
rolo the other day about equality and
what it means to be equal and i was
stressing over and over again a quality
of opportunity not a quality of outcomes
but that word of quality gets thrown out
a lot and it always always
look on social media when it's like
around equal pay day you will just see
stuff vomited out women make less but
but nobody does the dig
why and how much of that was of their
choosing if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]